Commentator: Hi everybody.
Thanks for coming out today.
It's a great honor for me to be up
here and, and present our artist today.
He's, he's known as simply the voice of South
Africa and he's been a great inspiration to me
and I'm, I'm sure a number of you as well
as many throughout South Africa and,
and Africa in general.
Grammy winning; performed for
the likes of Paul Simon, Dave Matthews,
Ladysmith Black Mambazo
and, and a variety of others.
I'm gonna keep it short because I think
like you, I wanna hear more from him.
Our, our guest today Vusi Mahlasela.
Vusi Mahlasela: Thank you.
[applause]
Vusi Mahlasela: Yep.
[pause]
Hello everyone.
Thank you very much it's a great pleasure
for me to be here.
And I think this will be
just more of my stories.
I'll be taking you through
my poetry and songs
and, yeah, I guess after that
we can have maybe questions also.
The song that I'm going to play for you
I'll sort of explain to you after
what's, what's the song about.
[tuning guitar]
♪ [melodic guitar playing]
Vusi Mahlesela: [humming]
♪ [singing in native language]
[humming]
[melodic guitar playing]
[applause]
Vusi Mahlasela: Thank you very much.
Yeah. The song I was singing
is titled Ubuhle Bomhlaba
meaning the beauty of our land,
or may I say the beauty of our country.
Here it wasn't only just singing about
the beauty of my country or the land,
but also about quite a lot of things which
were very disturbing and very sad you know.
To sort of like really witness that through
the time when it was really quite a lot of time
when in, in South Africa and Apartheid
where we also witnessed the police brutality,
police playing with our dead corpses,
thinking that we don't know about it is;
and here in this song I'm saying we will call
them and teach them about those corpses;
and if they agree we will forgive them.
But if they don't, we will expose them.
And of course this was written long
before we were putting that to work
or going to have you know the truth and
reconciliation in South Africa, if you remember.
The truth and reconciliation were just
something that of course it was championed
by our grandfathers of humanity,
Archbishop Desmond Tutu;
people who also were talking
about the wisdom of forgiveness:
Archbishop Desmond Tutu,
Dr. Nelson Mandela
and the man who lived in South Africa
many years
and planted a seed of reconciliation,
Mr. Mahatma Ghandi.
These are the grandfathers of humanity who
taught us that there is wisdom in forgiveness.
That if you learn to forgive you
learn more to be free.
You know to [inaudible] calmness within the
inner most of yourself and become more free.
But if you don't forgive,
you are your own prisoner.
If you don't forgive you are the one
who's suffering the most.
You will become like a bitter leaf
that can just be squashed
or be swept away by the wind anytime.
So forgiveness is very important and
we should all wear it like a crown.
Thank you.
This next is about a man that I came to
sort of like, like or love his writing and poetry.
This is about,
yeah, more the first part of
the poem that he wrote
and then there's the second part
which is more about, you know,
okay, the song will explain itself,
but the song is more about a cancer
[inaudible] from Nigeria
who was also killed by the forces of the state.
♪ [melodic guitar playing]
♪ They speak of Texas, of oil and power.
♪ They speak of war, of guns and bullets.
♪ They speak of blood and putrid human flesh.
♪ But a smile on my [inaudible].
♪ For my [inaudible ], for my [ inaudible].
♪ I say my love.
♪ Oh my [inaudible].
♪ [melodic guitar playing]
♪ We used to walk in a wave of dreams
all that I [inaudible] days with open sky.
♪ One fine day the love
we shared [inaudible] outside world
♪ And life begins to check our selfish feelings driven by the human nature.
♪ [singing in Native language]
♪ We used [inaudible] to the ways of love of,
♪ to the ways of life,
♪ to the way of life.
♪ One of those days when we used
to plant the seeds of happiness
♪ Singing lullabies to children.
♪ Telling these stories with no [inaudible] ending.
♪ [Chorus in native language]
[applause]
Thank you.
Okay, this next piece
[strumming guitar]
it is a poem also that was originally
one of South African jails
in solitary confinement and, yeah.
A prison warden, you know who was like
very much understanding, you know,
with hindsight. Just smuggle in a pen and this was
written on top of a toilet paper.
It's more about the pain of separation.
♪ [pensive guitar]
♪ La, la, la, la, la
♪ Oh, oh, oh
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh
♪ [inaudible] there are times when
hurting kicks its way in.
♪ Keeping us separated no [inaudible]
♪ When you [inaudible] let us [inaudible] become inseparable.
♪ Like a [inaudible]
♪ [singing in native language]
♪ La, la, la, la, la, la, la,
♪ [whistling]
♪ When you [inaudible] let us [inaudible] become inseparable.
♪ Like a [inaudible]
[applause]
[tuning guitar]
Okay.
This is a song called tuning.
[tuning guitar]
End of song.
This is a story of the two birds.
They lived in a dry land where there
was quite a lot of hunger and drought
and the other birds that didn't have wings
and the other one no eyes.
And they said "we have to
come up with a plan here.
It can't just be in stuff,
you know we have to do something."
And the other bird said: "Okay. Fine. Yeah.
We'll have to do this and fly somewhere,
so I'll be your wings and you'll be my eyes."
And indeed they both flew
to some greener pastures.
This is more also the story about
Mr. Nelson Mandela and, F.W. deKlerk
who was the President when
Mr. Mandela was released.
It's about both of them when they flew to
Norway to receive their Peace Nobel prize.
But I think also the lesson here it is
more about teaching us that we need
to honor each other as people.
♪ [upbeat guitar]
♪ [singing in native language]
[applause]
Thank you.
[tuning guitar]
This next piece, when I wrote this song
I felt of course at that time
I was writing it to some of my friends
who left the country
and even those who left before,
to skip their country to go outside to enlist
in a fight to fight the evil monster of Aparteid.
And yeah.
It was about those in exile
if when they come back their fears
and how, how will they found the country,
what position would be and then whether they
will find their families, jobs and things like that.
But it's also a celebration of life,
but I think it is something that I discovered
that also this song when I wrote it,
I thought I was writing it
for those people who went to exile,
but it was also about my life.
A road map for me to come back home;
find my paternal roots.
But, yeah.
♪ [melodic guitar playing]
And then of course right now
there is a new chapter for Africa;
a lot of good things are really
happening now and as you know
we are hosting the World Cup
for the first time in Africa.
I will be playing at the kick off concert
of the World Cup on the 10th of June.
So I'm happy that Africa
something made it happen.
♪ This is the unknow grave
♪ The one who died and in maintaing his mind.
♪ I'll start again so...
♪ This is the unknown grave.
♪ The one who died and in maintaining his mind.
♪ His will has been so strong and musically inclined.
♪ He is a sad man.
♪ He's coming out like a smoke from a wooden fire.
♪ Confessing who died last night.
♪ Who died this morning and why.
♪ One dangerous mind for millions of graves.
♪ Looked down into the grave and did not weep
♪ Skeleton confessing the loss of the music,
to encouraging him to believe.
♪ Skeleton confessing the age of lamentation,
the age of broken minds and souls.
♪ I picked up the soil from this lone grave
and blew it up into the wind,
♪ to make it a reference one day.
♪ And said, Africa.
♪ Sing loud Africa.
♪ Sing loud.
♪ Sing to the people.
♪ [inaudible] giving something to the world,
♪ and not just to take from it.
♪ [singing in native language]
[applause]
Vusi Mahlasela: Thank you very much.
This one is more about
when one was like touring,
going to quite a lot of different places,
meeting people,
shaking many peoples' hands.
Great.
And I remember also one time
when I was,
I did about 41 shows in 47 days
for the project called Across Africa
me and[inaudible] people
attend [inaudible] from Ivory Coast.
I don't think I'm going to do that again.
[laughter]
But it's always great, but sometimes
it's hard and it's like ah.
You get homesick and something
you just tell them Africa.
So,
[pensive guitar]
♪ We cross Zimbabwe's border
[singing a song describing a tour in Europe
and how everything relates to his Africa origin.]
[Lyrics are not decipherable.]
[applause]
Thank you.
I'd like to dedicate this one to
all the women in South Africa;
those women who refused to dwindle
in the mist of Apartheid
And of course dedicating it to my grandmother
also who really helped me a lot
as a young activist then,
I mean there have to be quite
a lot of problems with the police
and many other like her suffered
the same fate.
♪ [tuning guitar]
Okay, I stand.
♪ [singing in native language]
♪ Thula mama thula mama
♪ Through the mist of tears in your eyes
♪ On my childhood memory
♪ I know the truth in your smile
♪ Piercing through the gloom of my ignorance
♪ There is a mama lying down sleeping
♪ Very ill and heart crying
♪ Wondering, wondering, wondering.
♪ What is this world coming to?
Is it right
♪ That small children have to fend
for themsleves? No, no, no
♪ Is it right women struggling
in this uncertain world? No, no, no.
♪ Is it right heaping trouble on an old lady's head? [inaudible]
♪ Is it right I'm asking you damnit!
♪ [singing in native language]
♪ Thula mama thula mama
Thula mama thula mama
♪ Tomorrow it's gonna be better
♪ Thula mama thula mama
Thula mama thula mama
♪ Na hi ronama Na hi ronama
Thula don't cry Thula mama Thula mama
♪ [singing in native language]
♪ Baby, baby, baby...
♪ [singing]
♪ My song of love, my song of life
Everybody sing with me.
♪ My song of love, my song of love
I can't hear you.
You can do better.
♪ My song of love, my song of love
Okay. Okay.
Keep singing.
♪ My song of love, my song of life
[clapping]
Audience singing: my song of love,
my song of love, my song of love life.
Relax. Relax. Relax.
[laughter]
Thank you very much.
[applause]
I'll play you the last song and then
from there maybe you have some;
anything that we need to go by;
we can do justice to that.
And -
[tuning guitar]
♪ [Singing In native language.
Humming. Whistling]
[applause]
Thank you.
Q: This was a great honor to hear you today.
Thank you very much for being here.
I just wondered, would, would love
to hear from your own words
something about the role of music
in the struggle against Aparteid.
Vusi Mahlasela: Oh, Yeah.
Music played quite a lot of a role
during the time of struggle in South Africa,
even before myself was born.
It didn't before myself I was born.
There was quite a lot of music.
Those organizations from the BC,
Black Consciousness Movement,
example, up until it was like the UTF
and the unions and all that,
there was just more drive of
the music and all that.
I don't know, if you have seen
the, the film called "[inaudible]".
The struggle was engaged in four parts:
music, theater, writing.
And of course
when I, when I was born,
when I was young,
for me I didn't know that there was like trouble
in my country of injustice and so on.
So I came to realize this in 1976
when the students of South Africa
by [inaudible] to the language of Africans [inaudible] of oppression.
Where the students wanted to
speak to the government
and the answer was more bullets,
more bullets, more bullets.
I was eleven years old and this
escalated to other townships as well.
I remember in one [inaudible] it was
on the twenty-first of June.
And there was this people marching and
a lot of music and chanting and everything
and I was like: "Wow."
You know and I tried to ask questions
and yeah,
that's when my first political education started.
And there was just quite a lot
of music all over and everything.
And apart from that there has been
music that I've been hearing at home
because my grandmother owned a [inaudible]
what you call the speakeasy here
or I think yeah, pub.
And of course there'll be some songs
that I would hear as people
who would be singing in the backyard
and also [inaudible]
that was not allowed to be sung
around that time.
So music in many different ways
played quite,
it played quite a lot of role to
encourage people to stand up,
realize what
was really happening to them.
Through the message on the song it was telling
them what was happening around that time
and what they have to do.
Q: I was gonna ask about the languages
that you're singing in
and how many different languages,
you, you typically do sing in
and, or how many you speak and how -
you think about which, which languages
to use where in your songs
and how to, how to mix them together.
Vusi Mahlasela: Well I sing
in several languages in my music
and you know we have eleven official languages,
but still there are other languages
that people speak in the country
which are more dialects to other languages,
but you don't find that in a book form or in print.
And of course when I maybe compose for them,
it depends what comes first,
whether music or [laughs]
and sometimes it's good when I can come,
I mean incorporate both,
you know, the same time.
But sometimes it's just that the message
that you want to bring across
through the subjects that you are sort
of talking about, the song or poem,
whether you, you, you, you like it or not,
you might feel that no, I want everybody
to hear this and everything,
but you find that when you try to translate it
into English it doesn't work it looks,
it loses the, the meaning.
So rather [inaudible]
but it is something that maybe that's sort
of can work when I can order
and then I put it in English as well as
everybody or Kenyan, it's, it's okay.
Those are some of the things that
one sort of like really find.
And the song directs you
where they want to go,
and you just have to pay respect and attention
and follow the way the,
way they direct you.
Q: Hi. Can you tell us more about your work
in furthering education in Africa,
and maybe the African Leadership Academy?
Vusi Mahlasela: Yeah, there is a school
in South Africa which is called the Africa,
African Leadership Academy.
Well my role for, for the academy was more,
I, I performed, and at the opening years;
I think for the past two years.
And also a friend of [inaudible ]
who is also sitting on the board.
The guy who sort of like really started
the foundation,
I mean the academy we met at a [inaudible]
conference in Arusha this time.
And I think what is more important
about the African Leadership,
Leadership Academy developing leaders
for tomorrow like Nelson Mandela.
And I think with everything that
they were sort of like really [inaudible ]
so they have to hide back
and take it back to their,
to their places where they come
from and all that.
And I think maybe to explore
more coming to [ ]
'cause that is maybe in universities like Stanford and so.
But I think the African leadership
plays quite a lot,
important role in that cause.
But I've been touring as well here in
schools and universities giving talks,
now going to classes those who are
doing music, arts and music,
modern history, African history studies
other than the -
I feel also some of the students who are
in African Leadership Academy,
no, what am I saying,
not African Leadership Academy,
but that was my role this world now
to do these performances
and going to colleges and universities
as well to share my points and stories
in those classes I've mentioned.
Yeah.
Q: Thank you very much first of all
for the concert.
I really enjoyed it.
My question is really are you going to
be in the Bay area
and having other concerts so friends of
mine can get a chance to hear you?
Vusi Mahlasela: Are there
other concerts coming?
Q: Yeah, you know.
Vusi Mahlasela: Yeah. I'm, I'm, I'm going to
play at the Yoshi's in Oakland tomorrow.
And then I'll be also in Seattle after that.
And I've got a, a new CD
that I'll be recording.
After I finish in Seattle I'm going to
Charlottesville in Virginia
recording at Mr. Dave Matthews' studio.
So and then [inaudible] will be producer
for the album.
So the song that I play when I say
Africa will be one of the songs
which are in the album.
Q: Hi. My name is Finias
and I welcome you here.
It's, it was great to hear your music.
I actually just had a question
regarding kind of the motivation,
you touched on the aspect of African history
and you know keeping the word going
and how the young people receiving
your music nowadays
and how do you try to depict that
information through your music
with the current times and modern times
and the change in history?
Vusi Mahlasela: Yeah. I think it, it is very much important that
the youth today of course there's quite a lot of
things that they are really checking out,
taking especially through technology which is, and the music that they are making
with some of the effects and everything
that they do,
but I think to check where the raw thing
comes from is very much important.
Not only just about the music and then
perhaps the indigenous instruments
which are sort of accompanying
or something like that,
but I think the message as well
is very much important.
I think building up on that is like
after the post-Apartheid South Africa,
what I've witnessed is wild
and in sort of like a, the,
some kind of you know the ignorance
that you see in the youth forgetting
that the privileges and the rights
that they enjoy, they didn't just come by -
people fought for and died for.
And therefore they need some kind
of a counter revolution in some way.
And songs that say something about
where we come from,
how it had been so as to
make love today the future
is very much important that they hear this.
And it, it's, with what I'm doing as well
going to, to schools and colleges
and everything where the students are asking
questions and everything wanting to know,
it is very much important because art, music it's very power.
Through music you can sort of like really
bring out things that you want to address
whereas other people are afraid to say it.
But with the music you say it and freely without,
or write whatever you like and nobody
sort of like,
"No, you don't have to write that and do it."
And when people see you doing that they're,
"Ah. He can do that."
So then they have the courage to stand up
and do something about the situations
that they see or that they want to correct.
>>Q: Just a quick question
about your collaborations.
You've collaborated with some amazing
people and hearing your music today
it sounds very personal and very intimate
and you're telling a very profound story.
I wonder with these collaborations with
like Paul Simon or Dave Matthews,
how you establish that intimacy
or that connection with that artist
in order to present that forward in a song?
Vusi Mahlasela: Well, it is more about
just bringing the musical energy
it doesn't matter within whatever subject
and all that we sort of like really be
right in there in the song.
It's just to collaborate and if it is a song
that the artist has chose that is very special,
I want Vusi to come sing with me.
I, I don't have a problem with that;
I've collaborated with many artists,
Mr. Warren Haynes
a song called "Soulshine"
which I love the song.
And Mr. Paul Simon also led me to play
and sing his songs like "Under African Skies",
"Boy in the Bubble".
Then there, one artist also said,
"Look. Make the song your song.
Give your own treatment.
Don't worry that this is Paul
Simon's song or is whatever.
Feel the music."
Just, I, I love that.
And then when they also sing my songs, it,
it's also about that.
And I think this is when politicians
make difference,
participate that they can have collaboration to start our programs.
That will work.
Q: Hi. Just, just one question from me.
Thank you so much for your presentation.
My name is Dennis.
I work with Google in the Nairobi office
and I'm very passionate about
the role of language
in the adoption of technology.
So as a follow up to the question
about the role of music,
and music in, in indigenous languages and how you express that
and how that sort of gets people
into the struggle and that sort of thing.
What, what do you see as the role
of local languages like Soto and
so on getting more people
in South Africa to use technology,
to use the Internet,
to express themselves and participate
more freely on the Internet?
Vusi Mahlasela: Yeah. It is important
that people take proud,
I mean take pride in what they are
and especially in the language
that they speak.
It was this African idiom which says
[speaking native language]
which means a person is a language.
And if you learn to speak other people's
language we learn more to understand them,
to know them, to know their culture
and to love them.
So language plays quite a lot of
important role in the society.
And when you put a different language
in a song
and then also collaborate and sing
with other people,
we teach each other and
then it is like not about hate whatever;
just to pick a safe song and people
are sort of like,
"What language are you singing about
and what it is about?"
And it's really hard.
I read another book where the song lines
about from Aus--,
it's about Australia and the aboriginal
languages where they have,
they had this thing whereby
when you're traveled you learned.
They teach you a song in another
language and you have to travel
until you come to a certain point
at another border;
you get another people there,
they will teach you another song
in another language.
So it teaches you how to travel in a way
you can get water to drink in the wells,
but if you cannot study or learn the song,
you won't be able to travel.
You will get lost.
So you always have to, to learn
the language and different languages
everywhere you travel.
So you see that the language plays
very much important role
and there was a must that you have to learn
the language so that you may be able to travel.
And I think this is what we need.
Through technology and everything
whatever just for that the language
that we can all like.
Yeah. That's where immigrating
into a group or village,
the question is how much
do you want to belong?
I think the thing that will play important role
is the language that we have to learn,
each other's language and that way,
that way we can get by.
Q: Wow. Okay, excellent.
So does this mean you'll sing us a song
about using the Internet in sort of -
Vusi Mahlasela: [laughs]
Q: Well that's how you learn, right? So -
Vusi Mahlasela: [laughs] Thank you.
Female voice: Thank you. On behalf of
Google and the Black Googler Network
we thank you so much Vusi for sharing
your wonderful music with us.
We appreciate all you Googlers for coming
and making time out of your busy days.
I wanted to invite you all to remember
on 2/25, this Thursday,
we'll be celebrating more African music
and food in Seville
and just wrap this up and thank you
so much again for coming
and thank you, Vusi, again.
It was wonderful.
Vusi Mahlasela: Thank you.
[applause]